دعا في
الأمم المتحدة الديمقراطيات الغربية إلى البقاء متحدين ضد
الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا ، لذلك دعا بوتين
300000 جندي احتياطي إضافي
إلى أوكرانيا للانضمام إلى القتال ،
ويصر على أنه لا يخادع أه عندما
يتحدث عن احتمال استخدام
أسلحة نووية لبعض الناس  أعتقد أنه
يستعد بشكل فعال ويهدد
بالحرب مع الناتو ، هل ناقشت أنت والرئيس
بايدن كيف سيرد الغرب
ويتعين عليه أن يرد إذا
صعد بوتين الأمور بشكل أفضل أولاً
وقبل كل شيء ، لأن بوتين يفعل ذلك
لأنه لا يفوز ، فأنت تعلم أنه
صنع  غزو ​​خطأ استراتيجي
أوكرانيا وأعتقد أنه قد
تفوق عليه الأوكرانيون بذكاء ، لقد رأينا
أن الأوكرانيين يواصلون
صد الهجوم الروسي
وأعتقد أنه لم يتوقع نقاط القوة
في رد الفعل من العالم الحر
ويجب ألا نستمع  إلى قعقعة السيوف
وتهديداته الزائفة بدلاً من ذلك ،
ما نحتاج إلى فعله هو الاستمرار في
فرض عقوبات على روسيا ومواصلة
دعم  الأوكرانيون لأنه إذا
سُمح لبوتين بالنجاح ، فلن
يبعث ذلك رسالة مروعة في أوروبا
وبالطبع
تهديدات هائلة للسكان الأوكرانيين
أنفسهم ، بل سيرسل أيضًا
رسالة إلى الأنظمة الاستبدادية الأخرى في
جميع أنحاء العالم مفادها أنه من
المقبول بطريقة ما الغزو.  حسنًا على
سبيل المثال ، لكن من المقبول إلى حد ما
غزو دولة ذات سيادة لدولة ذات سيادة
، لذلك من المهم جدًا
أن نستمر في الحزم ولا نستمع
إلى قعقعة السيوف التي نسمعها
من بوتين ونستمر في دعم
الأوكرانيين  إلى التل وهذا ما
أصر على أن المملكة المتحدة
ستفعله ، وأنا أعلم أن الرئيس بايدن ملتزم تمامًا
من وجهة نظر الولايات المتحدة ،
لقد عملنا عن كثب مع حلفائنا الأمريكيين
مع G7 وسنواصل
القيام بذلك حتى المملكة المتحدة أوكرانيا  يسود